let's talk about the biggest football
tournament in the world the FIFA World
Cup and it's happening right here in
Qatar
more than one million football fans are
expected to travel to this tiny Gulf
Nation for what's going to be a World
Cup of many firsts
including the first to be hosted in the
Middle East it's a great event for my
country I'm very proud I'm so excited
that people are coming together to
actually experience it
and Qatar has built so much new stuff to
make it all happen
seven stadiums
a new airport more than a hundred hotels
new highways
and a new Metro
the total bill is coming in at something
like 200 billion dollars making this the
most expensive World Cup ever by a long
way we've basically seen an
international City emerge out of the
desert but it's also a World Cup that's
come in for a lot of criticism
especially over human rights issues and
qatar's treatment of the migrant workers
who've built everything
host country Qatar is facing growing
criticism over its treatment of women
migrant workers and the lgbtq plus
Community the team from Australia is out
with a video today that condemns the
country's human rights record I believe
a lot of the criticism is unjust I feel
like people have used
this as a way just to be able to bring
Qatar into disrepute Qatar is a
welcoming and hospitable country there's
nothing that fans should be worried
about all we have to do right now is
just to show the world what an amazing
World Cup this will be this country has
been looked at Cordon scrutinized for 12
years I think there's also a real kind
of determination from the organizers to
prove the world wrong so we're going to
take you through some of the basics
about Qatar explain some of the
controversies behind this world cup and
tell you what to expect from the
tournament
foreign
[Music]
qatar's capital and its only major city
Qatar is a desert peninsula in the Gulf
it's got only one land border that's
with Saudi Arabia Dubai and Iran are
also nearby they're just across the
water and Qatar is Tiny it takes roughly
two hours to drive from top to bottom
nearly 3 million people live here but
only 380 000 are actually Qatari
Nationals everyone else has come here
from all over the world to work in all
sorts of jobs
[Music]
but a lot of what you see in Qatar today
like most of these buildings it just
wasn't here even 20 years ago
[Music]
if we go back even further around 100
years qatar's biggest industry was Pearl
diving
but in the 1930s they struck oil and
then in the 70s they discovered Natural
Gas
today Qatar has the third biggest gas
reserves in the world
and that enormous wealth has been used
to transform the country
there is a huge Ginger huge difference
between 40 years ago and now today and I
remember in 2000s 2001 2003 if anybody
asked me where are you from and I say
I'm from Qatar they asked me another
question where is Qatar what is now they
just asked me how it's look like how
what is if we visit Qatar what do we
need how it's the culture the profile is
the growing
dramatically and the the and Qatari
government has succeeded actually in
establishing themselves in the world map
now on the political front Qatar is not
a democracy like its neighbors in the
Gulf it's a monarchy and the Emir
essentially runs the government right
now that's Sheikh tamim bin Hamad
al-tani but it was his father the
previous Emir who really kick-started
qatar's super fast growth came with a
new vision and Mission in his mind and
he wanted to develop the country whether
an education and Healthcare and media
and culture and sports Qatar actually
uses those as tools and it's soft power
but it's not just soft power qatars also
tried to position itself as an important
political player for example by
mediating between groups fighting in
countries like Sudan and Afghanistan
well I think there's a few different
goals that go back to a bigger strategy
over the last kind of 25 years or so
really thinking about the country as
trying to solidify for itself a kind of
a reputation on the international stage
and the ultimate expression of Qatar
wanting to be this big Global player is
hosting the World Cup the 222 FIFA World
Cup is Qatar
foreign
[Applause]
first got to bed I was over in in Zurich
for the announcement at FIFA
headquarters in 2010 the bid had started
in 2009 very much seen as an outsider
bit there was so many things against the
size of the country the weather the
perceived absence of football culture
here so I think when set blatter pulled
out Qatar from the envelope the whole
footballing world was just in a state of
shopping
while over in Qatar people went wild
SpongeBob
[Applause]
since then a lot has happened
[Music]
there were years of corruption scandals
at FIFA World football's governing body
the FIFA sky
Land seven people were now arrested as
Top members of FIFA's board and Qatar
along with Russia which hosted in 2018
was accused of essentially buying its
winning bid it's something that Qatar
has always denied we haven't seen
anything definitive proving that that
process was you know was corrupted but
certainly the the questions being there
I think already
you know cast certain doubts I think in
the minds of a lot of people
there's another Shadow hanging over this
tournament and that's the issue of Labor
rights and the working conditions for
the tens of thousands of people brought
in to do all the construction many of
them from countries in South Asia and
Africa
because Qatar like other Gulf countries
relies almost entirely on foreign
workers they play a key part of making
qatar's dream to host the swordka
possible and yet they were governed by
this very problematic system the system
created an over-dependence of Migrant
workers over on the employer or the
sponsor so this created this power
imbalance that actually drove labor
abuse and exploitation in the country
and across the Gulf region
things like not being allowed to change
jobs or leave the country without their
employer's permission not getting paid
and working in unsafe conditions and in
extreme heat
and workers have died during all the
construction linked to the World Cup but
the number of deaths is heavily disputed
now here's what qatar's Supreme
committee the organizers of the World
Cup told us in a statement despite our
commitment to our rigorous standards it
is unfortunately the case that as
elsewhere in the world work-related
injuries and deaths still occur on our
projects and there have been three
work-related fatalities and 37 non-work
related deaths but a report last year by
the un's international labor
organization suggests a more complicated
picture one that goes beyond just World
Cup construction projects it found
evidence of 50 fatal occupational
injuries in Qatar in 2020 alone mostly
in the construction industry and mostly
workers from Bangladesh India and Nepal
the ILO says it's hard to get accurate
numbers because of gaps in the data they
point to different institutions in Qatar
categorizing and investigating
work-related deaths differently so for
example there is a concern on whether a
large number of workers fatalities are
caused by heat stress and whether these
are not being properly identified as
work related
at the same time the ILO and rights
groups like Amnesty International also
say that qatar's government has done a
lot to improve things including
reforming the sponsorship system so that
workers can now change jobs or leave the
country without having to ask for
permission
I don't think any country can claim to
have done as much as Qatar has done in
the past 10 years to improve the working
conditions living standards the
introduction of minimum wage I thought
has been a Trailblazer in the region but
there are you know certain legitimate
criticisms to be raised at the same time
there are some that we've seen from some
segments and corners of the media and
other International audiences that have
tended to Veer a little bit toward a
kind of very racialized way of looking
at Qatar or kind of an orientalist way
of thinking specifically about Qatar as
if it exists completely outside of a
very you know troubling kind of
international labor system that is quite
exploitative the Qatari government has
said that the World Cup has been an
important Catalyst for improving workers
rights do you agree
yeah definitely I think the spotlight
that was brought by by this world cup
pushed the Qatari government to at least
commit to this to this reform process
and up until 2017 there was a bit of a
denial that there is an issue in 2017 we
saw a shift in the political will that
the government really kind of adopted DG
phone process so the principles are in
way better shape now but this
implementation ending the sculpture of
impunity ensuring that employers are
respecting the law and migrant workers
are fully protected from labor abuse and
exploitation that's where some gaps
remain
and it's not just labor rights the World
Cup has also drawn attention to other
rights issues in Qatar for example
homosexuality is criminalized here and
that's been a big focus of criticism
concerns are growing the Qatar is not
doing enough to ensure the safety of
lgbtq plus fans some of the teams have
raised the issue and the German and
English captains say they'll wear
rainbow armbands in support of the lgbtq
community the message from FIFA is to
focus on the football and qatar's
organizing committee says everyone will
be welcome I reiterate the message of
Qatar being a safe country a hospitable
country and I am confident that anybody
that comes to factor is going to feel
welcome and and safe
[Music]
most World Cup tournaments are spread
across several cities but this one is
super compact all eight stadiums are
either indocha or within an hour's drive
so if you wanted to you can go to more
than one match in a day
[Music]
but with all the fans concentrated in
this small area it's going to be a huge
operation to make it all run smoothly
will there be enough accommodation will
the traffic be gridlocked
will the new Metro be able to handle the
crowds
then there's all the new entertainment
they've prepared two newly built islands
with rides and restaurants and a huge
water park they're bringing in big names
for three music festivals and there will
be lots of fan zones
so right now this is obviously a massive
construction site but imagine this
packed full of football fans fan zones
will be among the designated areas where
people can buy and drink alcohol
alcohol will also be sold within the
stadium perimeters before and after
matches but it won't be allowed in the
stands all this is a change from qatar's
usual rules around alcohol normally
visitors can only buy it in some Hotel
bars and restaurants it's also illegal
to be drunk in public as long as people
are behaving in a in a way that doesn't
cause harm to themselves doesn't cause
harm to others there's no destruction of
property whether private or Republic and
people are generally
you know in good form then there
shouldn't be an issue at all
when it comes to local laws and Qatar
and it seems that things are going to be
a little more relaxed during the World
Cup but that still leaves so many
questions about exactly which laws are
going to be enforced and how
that's the thing about this world cup no
one quite knows how it's going to unfold
and a lot of different people have a lot
of different takes on it
but perhaps what's sometimes been lost
in all the discussions around Qatar as
hosts is another discussion about the
significance of the World Cup being held
in the Middle East for the first time
foreign
[Music]
have you been to a football match before
[Music]
we're obviously very proud that FIFA is
going to be in an Arab country as a
person coming from the Middle East we're
talking back in 2010 I was genuinely
very very happy for a country in the
Middle East to be able to host this Mega
sporting event to showcase our culture
so that for once I think the Arab world
would be associated with what we really
like Joy festivities and kind of steer
away from the perception of the Arab
world being Wars refugees terrorism
football has deeper Roots here than has
often been acknowledged and I think this
tournament is really an opportunity to
begin to kind of explore that history a
little bit more and to see the way that
the game has been truly globalized there
has to be a little bit more of an
acknowledgment that football
specifically is not the domain of sort
of one culture or one country or one
region the World Cup final will take
place in this Stadium on December 18th
it's also qatar's national day and
that's no coincidence for Qatar this
tournament is about out showcasing
itself to the world and they're hoping
the world likes what it sees
[Music]